we start directly on trailer a couple
days ago but I had videos to do to catch
up and now I did my uncharted 4 game
review and now we can talk about the new
Star Trek beyond rather because when the
first new music video - The Beastie Boys
came out I was in Los Angeles just out
that I was checking out the smog it's
good it's still there and I didn't get
an opportunity to talk about it so now
we're gonna talk about Star Trek beyond
well I don't need to fight anymore
though this isn't the 90s we know we can
love them both so this new trailer
starts out its ditched The Beastie Boys
music it's like alright alright
vans didn't like that so we'll just go
try their proper on this one almost like
they listened to fans with fans like
don't thank you as a fan this is
a better trailer this trailer starts out
Kirk is having doubts he's like my dad
joined Starfleet because he believed in
it I joined on a dare which I would he
not have doubts Khan kicked his balls
inning literally killed him alright died
from radiation but still which it
finally looks like they're in their
voyage their deep space voice they were
talking about that we saw them doing the
series ultimately throughout they're
always right with the world for
Starfleet puppies and Christmas and
Wonder then this swarm of robotic
just wrecks the enterprise and the crash
on this planet and pretty much what you
saw from the sabotage trailer but you
know done with better trailer music and
trailer tone and it looks like everyone
the crew and the enterprise and the
alien girls he's like I know why you're
here I know why we're all here so it
looks like the aliens on that world and
the crew of the enterprise are being
harvested for some odd reason to being
captured for a reason we don't yet know
the Borg
I don't really alright I don't
necessarily know I'm just saying it
would I always thought it would be cool
if they address something like the Borg
in these new Star Trek reboot because
semi-good the Borg the most infamous
enemies in Star Trek ever and their
coolest I just didn't think it'd be
cool Z's board but this trailer has some
cool lines it's just Spock he's like
fear of death is illogical but you can
tell he's afraid he's just trying to
like tell his own minds like hey don't
be illogical don't be illogical and
bones is like fear of death so what's
gonna keep us alive is totally true
that's why we have fear of death this is
what we stay alive but this trailer
looks cool with cool starts record stuff
and the first Beastie Boys trailer I was
kind of disheartened it's like alright
they're finally doing deep space they
wrecked their enterprises no more
enterprise so I guess they're not doing
that they didn't even record surgeon for
Spock it's just like a swarm of the
board came out of nowhere just start
beating out of their enterprise
they're conflicting stories amongst our
tract lore about the bar some say there
are hundreds of thousands of years old
some say they're hundreds of years old
I'm just saying first of all I
why I'm theorizing about those this much
and this one officially I'm here to talk
about the trailer and most of this video
I'm talking about my the Borg I'm
just saying they're harvesting people
for something they need them alive for
something but their tech seems to
operate almost like a swarm a hive mind
so to speak seriously look like a swarm
of bees beating the out of the
enterprise but it is interesting that
the batty tells Kirk hey your unity is a
weakness that kind of goes against the
entire philosophy of Borg unless they
create the first Borg in this movie and
then the Borg sees the humans win
against the who said unity is a
weakness and they're like hey
apparently unity is a strength let's
just assimilate everything and be
unified so given all that I see it in
the realm of possibility however
probably just outside the fringe of
likelihood that the events of this movie
are happening because there's some
on this planet that's harvesting
people because he's doing experiments on
them for the sake of creating a new
technology that's the merging of organic
and synthetic life the events of this
movie ultimately lead to the creation of
the Borg couldn't you say that no
whatever I was using this video as a
ploy to tell you how cool I think the
Borg are so rad I don't know why
I saw this trailer knows like every coal
is worth Borg I have no proof of
that but it'd be cool that mean
said if I'm wrong was the worst that'll
happen I'll just be wrong on the
internet star like I'm gonna hear about
it everyday sense theorizing on the
Internet you better be right if
you're gonna do that it looks like
it has exciting stuff if I have gripes
my only real gripe in this trailer is at
their new suits they don't pop the
colors are dull that doesn't look as
shiny and flashy as the suits and the
Abrams ones and I like the fashion of
the states in the Abrams ones that said
if we're talking about fairies you see
that should at the end people are like
whoa is that the enterprise from Star
Trek Enterprise of TV show I don't know
we're operating in an alternate universe
now so who knows maybe they found a
wormhole to but yeah this trailer looks
cool comes out comic-con weekend so I'm
either gonna get a review for it up
before I leave for comic-con or you're
gonna get a review of this movie after I
get back from comic-con don't know all I
know is the new Star Trek beyond trailer
without Beastie Boys music have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more